you say cyrus bienvenue dans le
quatrième épisode du coup de fil cette
fois ci on va étudier l'existentialisme
de jean paul sartre moitié des tarterêts
sur les dents jean paul sartre c'est un
philosophe français né en 1905 à paname
est mort il ya une trentaine d'années
donc philosophe relativement récent il
n'a pas inventé l'existentialisme mais a
beaucoup aidé à sa diffusion notamment
lors d'une conférence de 1945
d'ailleurs petite anecdote il faut
savoir que sartre était extrêmement
moche est très connu pour ses yeux qui
divergent totalement comme pouvoir sur
cette image divergent [ __ ] beaucoup en
gros le x100 séisme par de la phrase
suivante chez l'homme l'existence
précède l'essence pour comprendre un peu
ce que ça veut dire
faut déjà savoir ce que c'est les sens
sont si je prends un triangle
peu importe les points de vue il a
toujours trois côtés cessons à variance
son essence si je vais prendre un autre
exemple l'amour sous contrainte ça ne
marche pas donc la liberté fait partie
de l'essence de l'amour tu fais quoi
jean vous avec un bouquin de flouer doit
y avoir plein d'essence dedans avec
l'existence précède l'essence signifie
que on existe d'abord et ensuite on se
définit par rapport à nos actes pas
comme une boîte de mouchoirs vite par
exemple cette boîte de mouchoirs
on l'a d'abord pensé on a fait son
essence ensuite on l'a conçu et elle a
existé
vachon roubaix je balance nous prête un
mouchoir vrai bon gars et vu qu en
fonction de ce qu'on fait des choix
qu'on fait on ne devient pas le même nos
actes modifie notre essence si bien
qu'en fait notre essence elles changent
tout le temps sauf une fois qu'on est
mort bah parce qu'une fois qu'on les
morts on ne fait plus rien donc
à j + et du coup on va pas modifier
notre essence d'où la phrase chaque
personne est un choix absolu de soi ça
veut dire qu'on peut devenir qui on veut
et qu'en fait on a ce qu'on appelle le
libre arbitre savais pas que les
arbitres sortent de prison
ça sifflait à cette date mérite un
carton
et puis j'avoue je ne suis pas fou les
boules à trouver c'est ce qui se passe
dans harry potter c'est pas le choixpeau
qu'ils y arrivent à agri fond d'or c'est
harry qui demande au choix peau d'aléas
gryffondor c'est lui qui fait le choix
l'existence précède l'essence alors
pourquoi le choixpeau taquet envoyé à
gryffondor exactement harry exactement
ce qui te rend différent de voldemort
ce ne sont pas nos aptitudes qui montre
ce que nous sommes
ce sont nos choix une conséquence de
cette liberté c'est ce que sartre va
appeler l' angoisse l'angoissent
sartrienne mon par exemple si je suis
devant une falaise il va se passer deux
choses d'abord j'aurais peur de glisser
ou que quelqu'un pousse donc c'est une
peur externe
mais il ya aussi une peur interne qu'on
va appeler angoisse n'en vois ce qui
vient de ma liberté
le fait que je puisse sauter si j'ai
envie
le fait que j'ai foi en fait ça ça
m'angoisse parce que même si je ne veux
pas le faire je peux le faire et ça me
fait flipper c'est pour ça par exemple
aragorn refuse de prendre la no il sait
que même s'ils veulent détruire il
pourra peut-être pas et ne préfère ne
pas se retrouver face à ce choix outils
aux tests
on a tous déjà connu ce sentiment
notamment lorsqu'on a la diarrhée et
qu'on retient notre merde comme ça et
qu'on a peur 4 moment les muscles se
lâche parce qu'on sait que ça dépend que
de nous et que le muscle peuvent se
lâcher et déversé un flot de merde dans
notre pantalon
voilà et ça ça nous angoisse pour ceux
qui veulent aller encore plus loin et
voir comment je vais vouloir tuer cette
liberté qui me fait peur je conseille la
mauvaise foi donc en fait j'en parle
c'est une petite vidéo où je parle
pendant deux minutes de la mauvaise foi
peut-être un peu moins tourné fun plus
tourner philo donc vraiment si ça vous
intéresse
j'ai mis le lien aussi dans la
description de la vidéo pour les autres
j'espère vraiment que c'est plus clair
ici le twitter et s'était pas passé le
coup de fil à un ami
mais la mecque